know thyself but thyself is an illusion  a wise man sees a different world as the  conclusion  humans causing earth to cause a  pollution wake up and see our hearts are  the solution brown black or white is the  distraction replaced the oppressive  bureaucratic contraption life inside  each of us is a divine reaction rise up  peacefully as the unity faction this  entire civilization is one big story if  you wake up too slow it goes by all  blurry  each of us have tenderness that we call  Gurley our characters level up as we  progress surely gain points by helping  others awaken when the mind expands the  body gets shaken shed the old and  embrace the new this right here is the  year we pull through